so as we continue our discussion
surrounding you know Wolverine related
content in response to the trailer for
Logan having been released what I do
here is I want to talk about how I want
to talk about how Wolverine killed all
the super villains now this is this
actually comes to us as issue 111 of the
what-if line of stories now for those of
you guys who know about what is bear
with before a second well I've run over
this
for those who don't if you're coming
from DC Comics the what-if line of
publications are similar to what you
call Elseworlds the difference here is
that Elseworlds are just stories that
are out there they don't usually tie
into the existing continuity the what-if
stories in Marvel Comics do so it's like
what if you know
Wolverine had killed the Incredible Hulk
when the two of them first met when
Wolverine first appeared in Marvel
Comics it was in a battle with the
Incredible Hulk the what-if story is
based on what if Wolverine had killed
The Incredible Hulk
in that battle then how would the
conflict turn out or how would the world
turn out there's stories like what if my
Aunt May had died instead of Uncle Ben
there are some really cool stories like
that but they always have their roots in
the main continuity for those of you
guys who are not coming from DC comics
that are just you know kind of curious
about Marvel in and of itself the same
idea still applies that Marvel has one
straight universe which is called the
earth-616 continuity and all the what if
stories are just alternate realities
that branch off of that now this
particular story actually has its roots
and Wolverine becoming a Horsemen of
apocalypse now the way this worked was
that and the mid 1990s comic books have
just been struggling in general and so
the goal was to try to reinvigorate them
and keep them interesting but at the
same time Wolverine had lost his
adamantium in a battle with magneto
during the events of fatal attractions
which I actually have a video on but
because of this Wolverine was
effectively sent off into the wild where
he became what's called feral Wolverine
and his comics actually lasted this way
for quite some time the issue with this
was that it wasn't a story that could be
done forever Marvel eventually had to
find a way to bring him back to make him
into the Wolverine that we always knew
and so what they did is they basically
initiated a story where the villain
apocalypse had kidnapped Wolverine and
Sabretooth and basically said whichever
one of you wins in a battle to the death
will not only you know become my
horseman war but will also receive
enhancements and so because well rain
was still relatively feral at this point
because he was a far more capable
fighter than Sabretooth was he
ultimately killed Sabretooth and in
doing so apocalypse restored his
adamantium to his bones and made
Wolverine into the horseman war now in
that original story Wolverines
brainwashing was basically worn off by a
combination of Jubilee and the rest of
the x-men who were able to talk him down
and bring him back in this story that
didn't happen instead Wolverine remained
the horseman Ward and so what we do here
is we initially pick up with a group
called the war watch and the war watch
basically just functions to ensure that
the world stays safe this is actually
one of the really cool concepts here
because in this you know in this future
there is no war between humans and
mutants that humans and mutants are
basically living in peace at Xavier
dream of a peaceful coexistence between
humans and mutants has actually come to
fruition in addition to this we also see
that this what seems to be this
fledgling group of young officers are
brought in at the behest of their
sergeant and they're basically told that
there is a group calling themselves the
Wolf Pack who are basically a gang that
have been running amok and they've been
attacking stores now what this tells us
is that in this future that there is
still violence violence is very rare it
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's quickly snuffed out and that
these young people are a combination of
regular humans and mutants who have come
together under the banner of the Wolf
Pack and begun engaging in violent acts
and so what is it happening is the world
watch of course bands together these
police go out to the mall they attack
these young people they basically they
grab them they throw them or at least
they seem to subdue them with with gas
and then they take them you know and
have them arrested accordingly the whole
question is how did things get to this
point you know at what moment did
everything seem to change and what we're
told or at least what we're given is the
sort of quick rundown on the history of
Wolverines life what we know is that
before he joined the x-men Wolverine was
a part of a group called a tough flight
as part of Canada's department cake
which was Canada's superhero team the
idea was that as part of alpha flight
you know Wolverines served to carry out
government actions and so on and so
forth but eventually his journeys
brought him to the attention of the
x-men not only that he had of course
received his adamantium upgrades by
virtue of the Weapon X program but in
light of all this when the time came
whereby
he was made a horseman of apocalypse
because the x-men either didn't come to
his aid or didn't arrive fast enough
that immediately after he became the
horseman war he killed apocalypse right
off the bat now something to point out
here is that this is entirely possible
apocalypse yes he has
celestial technology yes he's wildly
powerful he's one of the most powerful
mutants in existence he can alter his
size to virtually anything but Wolverine
having adamantium makes him virtually
indestructible and because there's
really no metal that that apocalypse
could be in possession of with the
exception of adamantium itself that
could keep him safe from Wolverine he
was easily killed by Wolverine now this
is also kind of funny too because those
are the guys who ever watched x-men the
animated series whatever Wolverine uses
cause on apocalypse it never worked
that was actually an error that was a
mistake in the show that his claws
should have easily torn through
apocalypses armor but the fact remains
here that after becoming the horseman
war he basically embarked on a crusade
to kill off every single super villain
he came across we killed off the
juggernaut he killed pyro he killed
magneto he killed him all he killed
arcade who was a small-time villain that
basically used tricks and things like
that he's like Marvel's version of the
Riddler but the fact remains here that
he killed anybody he was much like The
Punisher he killed anybody who was
involved in governmental corruption who
was involved in trafficking it didn't
matter if they were mutants it didn't
matter if they were humans if they were
political officials if they were your
average joes he killed every single bad
guy anyone who had ever done anything
nefarious in the Marvel Universe the
problem with this was that the heroes
also recognized that if allowed to
continue unchecked that Wolverine would
basically become a detriment to the
world as a whole and so all the
superheroes of the world came together
and they began forming their own
governments their own or against their
own groups and organizations so the
Avengers went against Wolverine thie
Inhumans went against Wolverine the
x-men went against Wolverine and he
killed every single one of who he killed
every last one and so in response the
humanity and what was left of the mutant
population banded together and formed a
group called war watch and war watch was
designed to quite literally keep tabs on
what it was that Wolverine was doing and
eventually find him and bring him in the
problem was that they were never really
successful in doing that suddenly
because of the fact that if Wolverine
doesn't want to be caught then he
won't be caught and so what this does is
this continues along the path of one of
these young recruits who goes to the
Hudson Bay wash grounds which is kind of
like the next step in the in the war
wash not only that he's also become a
little bit disillusioned with everything
that's going on and so in his journeys
he actually comes across a monk who
seems to be in hiding or the very least
seems to be just kind of watching all
these things unfold and the idea is to
learn from him everything he can not
only that this person's operating under
the mantle of brother Xavier and so the
initial idea is maybe this is Charles
Xavier maybe Charles Xavier was the last
surviving guy in addition to this what
brother Xavier also does is he gives an
account of Wolverines history and saying
that not only you know did he turn
against various villains but he also
fought people who were allies at one
point in time again tying in to this
element of killing off the the various
superheroes and the various
supervillains that existed and so in
response to this basically what he did
is he recognized the fact that some
aspect of his personality the Wolverine
was always doomed to be the horseman war
that all that you know becoming the
horseman war did was allowed this dark
aspect of his persona to completely
emerge and allow the humanity of who he
was to be cast aside and so in the end
what we learn is that this person that
this young man's been talking to is
actually Wolverine himself in addition
to this once they get you know back to
normal society that when the war watch
is still trying to deal with this gang
this wolf pack that's you know running
amuck throughout various cities that
Wolverine actually comes to their aid
and Wolverine is able to stop every
single one of these kids not only that
this guy you know some of these people
also recognize that it seems to be will
reign himself and so once this meeting
between the two is completed once this
young man officially allows himself to
be inducted into the end of the order of
monks which are part of this this war
watch once he's become kind of a I guess
a leader so to speak that Wolverine
officially reveals who he is and tells
him that the goal is to always keep
conflict at bay the goal is to always
keep battle at bay and then it's a
never-ending fight in order to achieve
this goal having said that I don't know
if you guys feel like I do this is one
of the worst written stories that I've
ever seen in the history of my life this
is so badly written it's not even funny
but it is still an interesting concept
with Wolverine taking on the entirety of
the superhero in the supervillain
community but because I don't like to
focus on the negative we're going to
bring this to an end
but post them in the comments let me
know try to be nice to each other guys
trying to be civil post a comment down
below and let me know what you guys
think about this story whether you
thought it was good whether you thought
it was bad what you thought the case may
be and if you're new here to comment to
explain make sure you hit the sub button
become part of the Rob core you may or
may not get a shiny new ring and yeah
make sure you guys drop a like and I
will catch you guys later peace
[Music]